[Music]
[Music]
hey Greg knuckles here with string
theory calm string with an e and only
one th people are saying strength theory
it's not a string theory the name of my
websites a pun it's hilarious roll with
it anyways
today we're talking about head lifting
people who have been reading my site for
a while know that I have started a
series where I'll be going through what
it took to hit different milestones with
each flip going in hundred pound
increments for squat and deadlift and
fifty pound increments for the bench
press and people who follow my site also
knows that I've only written the first
installment for each one but that's
going to change one of these days I
promise anyways today we're starting
with the deadlift and as the series
progresses you'll notice that the advice
becomes more and more specific in each
installment so this one is 500 pounds
which I pull relatively early in my
lifting career so most of the advice
it's going to be fairly general because
well it was that first big milestone I
did so it didn't really take that much
in-depth knowledge to get there the
first thing is simply to grease the
groove of the deadlift pattern I find
that of the free lips this is probably
the least important for the deadlift
simply because the deadlift is kind of a
more natural movement there are a lot of
things you do in day-to-day life where
you have to bend over pick something up
off the floor pick something up for me
height pickup furniture to move it
something like that however there are
very few things that you do that involve
putting something very heavy on your
shoulders squatting all the way down and
coming back up with it though squats
they take a bit longer for people to
acclimate to bench press kind of depends
I found on people's athletic backgrounds
especially people from a military
background
if even if they haven't lifted weights
much they've done
of push-ups so benchpress tends to come
naturally to them some people without
much of an athletic background haven't
really ever done push-ups or anything
like that
benchpress tends to have a bit more of a
learning curve
deadlift though most people tend to pick
it up fairly quickly when this article
was originally published something that
people tended to be incredulous about or
was the deadlift I did the first time I
touched a barbell was 11 years old I got
a little weight set Christmas when I was
in sixth grade and a total of is either
200 or 250 pounds and I really can't
remember was one of the two I'm trying
to visualize exactly what weights came
with the bar and which ones I got later
I know at one point I had one more set
of twenty fives which would have made it
to 50 I can't remember if those were
there on Christmas Day or it was just
200 pounds
either way that's not overly important
but it was either 200 or 250 and so you
know I'm 11 I don't know any better I
have all of this weight so I think hey
can I pick this up so I went down to the
basement loaded all of the weights on
the bar keep in mind the biggest plates
were 25 pounds instead of 45 so it was
actually a bit of a deficit that book
and it was actually pretty easy um I
pulled it for I think three three or
four reps and then we're like okay I can
do that that's fun and because it was
relatively easy I didn't really deadlift
too terribly much more after that
anyway so the reason I think I could do
that one I'll be the first to admit I
have good genetics for picking up heavy
things but the other thing is I simply
had a fairly active childhood we live
out in the woods and we always book
burned a wood fire during during the
your time and so spring and summer we
would cut down trees or if a tree had
fallen we cut it up and you know logs
about that that a big in diameter about
that long hmm depending on how big the
tree was the individual pieces would be
somewhere between fifty hundred and
thirty pounds somewhere in that range
and basically I spent my childhood
picking up those chunks of wood and
loading them on the back on the back of
a trailer and then at Christmas after
splitting the logs and whatnot
we had a wood pile that was a decent
ways from the porch and so we load the
wood up in a wheelbarrow have to push
the wheelbarrow uphill then toss the
wood up onto the porch so I had I guess
which you could call a fair amount of
GPP grit deadlifting before I actually
ever got to lift weights and I did I did
always just like picking up heavy things
so when we were sawing down a tree we'd
start from the top the skinniest pieces
and work towards the bottom which would
be the thickest pieces and I would
always it would kind of be like a stone
load ladder I'd pick up you know I'd
start with the smallest ones and just
pick up the heaviest one that I possibly
could until my dad had to take over from
me so you know that's very similar to a
deadlift and so you know I basically
been dead lifting since I was five years
old so the movement came very very
naturally to me that's way more
background than you needed that's fine
whatever I was good at deadlifts the
first time I tried and a lot of that was
because I had very much greased the
groove by the time I actually got my
hands on a barbell number two is you
simply have to commit to the pole
deadlifts can be much more
psychologically intimidating than squats
or benchpress can because we can
actually start the lift you know you
have to unwrap the bar first either back
first quad and your hands for bench you
feel it the weight feels like and you
can kind of mentally assess am I ready
to lift this way or not
deadlift on the other hand it's just a
lifeless bar on the ground and it's
they're taunting you and you have no
idea what it feels like until you
actually put your hands on the bar and
rip it off the floor that tends to get
in a lot of people's brains I know it
does for me a lot of times I miss bed
lifts simply because I don't commit to
the pole right and that was one of those
lessons that I learned early early on
you simply have to be in the right
mental state the dead looked to dead
look heavy and that means you know if
you're going to get psyched for a heavy
lift it had better be a deadlift if
you've watched my videos you know that
I'm quite a big Katy Perry and Taylor
Swift fan that's my lifting music of
choice most of the time but deadlift is
always Rage Against the Machine day
simply because you know you can get
focused to Katy Perry and Taylor Swift
as well you should
throughout most of your life however for
deadlift you need to put on calm like a
bomb or killing in the name of something
like that it's much more apropos for the
situation
okay so fast-forward a few years from
when I pulled that initial 200 when I
was 11 or so the first time I got my
hands on in Olympic sized barbell set
with forty fives and whatnot I was 14
and I pulled 405 in the high school
weight room we didn't really have
deadlifts in the program but the coach
just wanted us to max on deadlifts one
day because that's smart programming and
that was in October and then we didn't I
didn't really deadlift again until I
started training with a powerlifting
team in April or May
and so in April or May I was still
looking about 405 however after only
four or five months with that program
that was very very focused on posterior
chain development I pulled my first 500
at the 100% role youth or high school
state championships that was that took
place late in that summer so it only
took four or five months to put that
first hundred pounds on
I'd live and I really wasn't deadlifting
too terribly much during that time
period because again what side style a
deadlift much conjugate method blah blah
blah but simply because of how much work
we did for our posterior chains I put
that first hundred pounds on my deadlift
pretty quickly and so that got me to 500
which was the point of this video what
it took in what I had to learn pull my
first 500 pounds number one breeze the
groove number to learn how to commit to
the pull get out of your own head
put on some Rage Against the Machine and
number three focus on posterior chain
development because that's what you did
look quick alright guys thanks a lot for
watching if you liked the video and
you'd like to see more stuff like this
please like and subscribe
got questions ask them in the comments
below may make a response video I don't
like them I won't make a response video
but I still love you
I thanks guys bye